spider-man swings back in action with
all new overcharged adventure across the
90s meticulously hand-drawn art work
clean digitally painted backgrounds and
on model colors all combined to make
this one the most authentic looking fan
comics ever made
daring battles shocking reveals
never-before-seen crossovers and more
villains than you can shake a web at
grab a copy this you wanted to get in on
the action today I swear this is really
this is being a youtuber is what why did
it stop recording it was going fine and
then and then getting upset and then
crumble to the big leagues kid and then
having to start over all start all over
again
just be thankful we didn't do the whole
thing and then it did that anyway what
hi welcome this is a podcast about
spider-man 94 our cool fan comic that
people seem to enjoy that will work on
more issues so please stop asking me on
the comments and the DMS we're doing
which we're working on it ok it's day to
head the [ __ ] end of the last page
it's said to be contended and then it
had an ellipsis with 4 dots which really
pissed me off because it's supposed to
belong three
you could have cropped it no it had to
be the one from the show it had to be on
model know someone would have pointed it
out everyone always points that [ __ ] out
if it wouldn't have been them it would
have been one of you - wouldn't you -
but it would have been like why'd you
take out the fourth dot I'll color in a
new one working on the comic was really
fun particularly the last two days where
we were like panicking trying to get
everything done and ready by the
deadline of the 25th anniversary of the
show and there was parts like way late
at night the night before the comic went
live where I had to react sport the
whole book about I would say 11 times
because because Jacob kept finding stuff
he wasn't happy with and telling me to
fix it
and in the process of trying to fix it I
accidentally bumped a panel and like I
was like clicking around kind of furious
trying to make sure everything was good
and I guess I accidentally clicked on
one of the word bubbles in my program
and shrunk it just a little bit so that
it caught a word in half yeah you like
that pick nine i [ __ ] up on page nine
and I didn't notice it because it was
fine before that and then I had to fix
it the following day and there's still
copies of it online like on the website
where it's not correct but on the Google
Drive in the PDF it's fine because I
don't think Danes ever been on the
channel before let's say no Jacobs a
recurring guest guest matters but Dane
here is a fantastic super friend he and
I have been working together for like I
don't know two or three years now just
like chasing our dreams trying to make
comics and so far two of them have come
out which is in my opinion a good number
and he's honestly one of the nicest
people I've ever met and I'm honored
like every day to be able to work with
someone as talented as him and the fact
that he doesn't already have some kind
of job as an artist in the industry is
nothing short of a war crime I'm also
thankful for it at the same time because
instead of drawing like official books
he's over here drawing my stuff and I
get to I get to exploit his talents to
have the loss meme reenacted by
abomination with that lead-in if they
can identify you via voice well I think
I think you did a pretty good job I'm
just a humble pencil man that's true
anyway you guys know me I'm not [ __ ]
annoying child Diaz on the channel
sometimes my teenage sidekick that's me
he's white miles
anyway kiddo if yeah you want to get
through high school you just gotta
actually go that's my advice that's not
what you told me on this channel that's
not what I told you two years ago which
is which was don't take it too seriously
high school senior year oh [ __ ] yeah cuz
you're just starting high school and
you're like hey can you give me any
advice and I was like don't worry about
it just just [ __ ] skip school all the
time it's hilarious it is skip school
all the time and then color something
for me I skipped school all the time
commit crimes and all for my dress up is
Spider Man constantly we're not dressed
up as spider-man right now you're doing
something incorrect like you have any
shortage she's eight I haven't counted
mine dana has a mask from me oh yeah so
that's another thing is that uh people
may have seen on my Instagram and the
trailer we did for the comic is I have a
spider-man 94 mask that was made by
Jacob and all three of us have one as a
celebration of the the book coming out
he made everyone working on it a special
spider-man 94 mask we also all have mugs
oh yeah oh yeah
I remembered see I'm the good boyfriend
I remember things I said we all have big
comic penises but no yeah we also have
bomb squad comics mugs Dayne designed
the bomb squad comics logo that's on a
lot of the merch I think we actually
have that listed as him as the artist on
the on the side do we if we don't we
need to know does it say this was
designed by so-and-so in the in the
description because if it doesn't I've
done a big oops
I'm getting self-conscious about it now
I gotta go look
t public anyway you guys talk whenever I
get like distracted by something or slow
down for a few seconds uh well anyway oh
my god it doesn't say drawn by Dane I
[ __ ] up I need to I need to write some
emails I need to go talk to some people
hey I just realized the kingpin is not
in our comic yeah he's just [ __ ]
chilling inside that's his secret lab
and accra in the Chrysler Building when
I saw that building in movies as a
little kid I was like man kingpins bases
and those big size they [ __ ] they
have big hydraulic like doors on him
that slide down so he can park his
helicopter inside the hobgoblin can
terrorize him I'm the Green Goblin and
then he's now the cannon first one even
though it wasn't how it was in the rest
of the show that's one of our favorite
continuity errors in that show is that
they just start like Green Goblin starts
calling the Hobgoblin a knockoff even
though he existed like months before him
so uh what should we which we talked
about today uh well for one I guess we
should talk about our experience working
on the book regardless if the QA
questions asked that I think it's just
an important topic to cover
I remember one question did ask us when
did we start working on this when did we
start working on this fellas it was you
started writing it around March and the
planning area was doing like February I
think yeah yeah I was planning it like
early on in the year I actually wrote
like I would say maybe the first the
first issue I wrote was actually the
fourth one because Leo yeah you're right
I was more familiar with some of the
subject matter in that issue which I
will not spoil because it felt a little
bit more natural to write that at the
start and then after I went back and
re-watch the whole show I what felt more
comfortable going back and writing like
issue 1 because I wanted it to feel off
dick but it was hard to throw myself in
the issue one he started writing the
script in like late March for issue one
and then like I don't know if he
finished it and then Dane started
drawing it but I know that the first
fully completed page was April 15th so I
started working on it in April I mean we
should also preface this whole thing
this whole thing was Danes idea yeah
that's true
um I recall like one of the first
conversations that we had were me and
Dane were in a voice chat he was like
look I have I found the most important
model she first the spider-man animated
series from the 90s it was Petersham
particularly drawn-out hamper from like
three different angles because it's
really important you don't get that one
wrong he throws his costume into it
probably in one episode you gotta get it
right that's it what the [ __ ] so yeah
this whole comic spawn from we're just
making jokes because where'd you find
the mommy sheets we're like did you just
clicking around on the internet one day
and fatum or like oh [ __ ] I can do so
much with this oh yeah yeah I can talk
about that i i i wanted to do like a
spider-man animated show with my buddy
william cuz he's the one who animates
all the socially inept spider-man stuff
and he was very particular about how we
made the models which was like basically
building them in blender over a 2d model
sheet and no matter how many times we
tried we could not find a good enough
model sheet nor could we make one that
was like to his exact specifications to
do that process but while we were
working on that I asked Dane to get us
some model sheets or to try it with and
he drew some really awesome one
that maybe you know what you can
probably put those out cuz I mean you're
not getting [ __ ] post though they're
so good like it's a shame I said yeah so
[ __ ] upload those at some point put
those on Twitter or the instagrams cuz
they're really good but uh yeah so he
worked on those and I guess you found
the the ones 494 is like a is like a
reference for how to do them well I kind
of stumbled upon them after the fact
because I kind of knew how to do them
I'm like well okay these actual ones by
professional artists yeah yeah cuz
they're like their job is to draw the
same thing
identical proportions from multiple
angles over and over and over and then
it's just yeah that whole treasure trove
of model sheets just stuck in my brain
and I'm like well use these for
something you know pretty good
restaurants for the show yeah and what
the thing the nice thing was that like I
don't know if it was intentional or not
but your art style like you just when
you're drawing by yourself just I'm
gonna draw a picture of the Punisher or
whatever like it's already kind of close
to the art style from the show so it
wasn't like this huge leap in you know
drawing something new like maybe maybe
certain like character proportions are a
little bit rounder or like the faces are
a little bit wider but other than that
it's pretty much the same you really
study under the tutelage of like Bruce
Timm and junior junior right like really
kind of blocky kind of angular art
styles which I think are really cool and
underappreciated
John Rooney jr. Tim sail and Walt
Simonson probably the most influential
artist in my style my work I also see a
little bit of a Mike Mignola in there
sometimes say his name like
subconsciously oh I guess that guy's a
master of layouts yeah it's like red
times a Hellboy and
that's why I sent you that Hellboy Lego
yeah I a couple months back at comic-con
I found like this like custom Lego guy
who like he had a booth where he was
just making like really specific ones
that like actual Lego didn't have the
rights for and I kept seeing all kinds
of cool ones that I thought my friends
would like so I said Jacob the Marvel
Zombies spider-man cuz him and I are
always talking about how much we were
traumatized by Marvel Zombies return he
[ __ ] shoots his veins and arteries
out from yeah that's his webs his veins
and arteries and that traumatized me
like I loved the rest of Marvel Zombies
but that one in particular I'm like oh
why is it gotta be so [ __ ] mean to
Spider Man why is this why I'm sorry
when I first saw it I maybe that's why
it didn't affect you as bad cuz I
remember I read Marvel Zombies 1 when I
was like that age and a couple years
later I read return and by that point I
was old enough for it to sink in it's
like oh my god they're doing storable
things despite her man when Spiderman
was just having his [ __ ] [ __ ] just
ruined cool and I like Spider Man this
is cool yeah then I grew up and I was
ladies
it's still cool I I find Marvel Zombies
like one through three awesome and I
love them I don't remember much about
the fourth other than that like Deadpool
was a talking ahead and then he hangs
out with Simon the white zombie or
whatever and then Marvel Zombies
returned like burned my crops and killed
my dog so you may notice that there's
not a lot of sound effects in the comic
really like if there are it was like
you're someone with that there's some
flips that I feel like they're it's
mostly for moments we were like it would
have felt weird if there wasn't a sound
effect but for the most part I don't
really write them in a whole lot cuz one
of my biggest influences as a writer is
Garth Ennis and like as soon as he
started riding Punisher max where he
didn't have to put that [ __ ] in he just
stopped and like I kind of I for some
reason I felt like yeah this just kind
of makes the comic better I don't know
I've kind of changed my opinion of it
now I feel like sound effects are like
useful at certain times so maybe we'll
start seeing them more like later issues
while I'm lettering I'll just throw them
in or something but I've avoided that a
lot back then for whatever reason yeah
like there's a lot of explosion shots
that you know the art just speaks for
itself
yeah I mean what you do you need to know
what the explosion sounds like you can
you can just guess you know what an
explosion sounds like I'm sure you've
heard that before in a movie whoever you
are listening to this but uh yeah so
Dane kind of pitched the idea of it to
me one day he's like hey together what
if we wrote like and and drew like a
continuation or finale for spider-man
and actually I had two different ideas
for at the same time
and even like to intuit at first I don't
think no I was like alright I guess I
mean that could be fun I mean I it's the
thing is as much as I like the show now
I didn't quite I wouldn't say I really
grew up with it quite the same way I did
with other cartoons like I had all the
VHS holes that they put out what'd you
say I said beast beast wars yeah we're
talking about Beast Wars 3 Kim B's these
as they called it in Danes homeland
I guess Wars was too violent their their
helicopters are still from the 70s
anyway yeah so like I didn't quite grow
up with the show like I watched the VHS
tapes that they put out of it like all
three or four of those and then I had
the venom Saga on DVD and I just kind of
watch those but that's like that still
maybe like 20 out of like 70 episodes
and all the rest were just maybe I'd
catch him as a rerun on TV every once in
a while but other than that I really
didn't watch like the show religiously I
mean it was also a little bit before my
time because it was like over by the
time I was even born and I I remember
not liking some parts about it as a kid
- I was like why does spider-man talk to
himself so much and I didn't realize
that that's awesome and I wish every
spider-man thing would do that I just
said like well like what month did it
and then because I think it ended in 98
oh well I mean even then like I was if
it would have been I would have been
like three weeks old or something but uh
eventually when Dane pitched the idea to
me I was like yeah that sounds pretty
cool I could get behind that I guess I
mean sure whatever and I don't know I I
said yes right away cuz I just I jump at
the
working with dane unlike anything but i
wasn't like that into it and then I
started like rewatching episodes of it
and like really getting a feel for it I
was like hey hey yeah this is awesome
why didn't I like this as much as a kid
you start to go to spectacular you
started texting me like while you were
rewatching it like things like I
remember the sound design in the show
not being as good as it actually is like
I remember them having like one sound
effect for punching and [ __ ] oh yeah I
remember like I guess there's like three
sound effects from the show from when I
was a kid that always stuck with me it
was the web sound effect the flip sound
effect or that whoosh and then the sound
of spider-man's little feet
pitter-patter on like roof tops the
clapping noise and that's all I remember
is just like those on loop forever and
it's not quite that bad they do have
like variants of those but when I
described them be you just now you know
exactly what I was talking about so yeah
I I guess I like I didn't have like the
fondest memories of it like I didn't
hate it or anything but I just like it
wasn't like this thing that I was like
super in love with until I went back and
and like really got back into it cuz if
it was gonna feel like that aunt ik I
need to know how the characters spoke so
I could get their voices right and
absolutely it took me a second again is
cuz like spider-man's references need to
be like dated but not too dated the he
needs to kind of speak like a little bit
his vocabulary needs to be a little bit
too wide he needs to be a little bit too
articulate for casual conversation when
he's spider-man cuz like when he's Peter
Parker he just kind of talks like a guy
but as spider-man for some reason he's
he's just like using a lot of like you
know $10 words people so I had to figure
out the kinds of words he would use
during certain scenes
and I had to figure out it like how does
Doc Ock speak like it has to sound like
the the actual voice actors could sit
down and read this this comic out loud
and it would not be wrong you did it a
lot of people were complimenting you on
that that was that was one of the most
important things from a script wining a
script standpoint was just making sure
that was right because if you get that
right everything else just kind of falls
into place I guess we've talked about
penciling and and wording now yeah go
ahead [ __ ] go off so time to shine
baby boy the process for coloring this
and there's actually a question early on
and it like because I'm at this section
and when we got to this section last
time the recording wasn't good so check
that really quick oh yeah that might be
the curse said one
oh let me look there and now let's see
yeah it still says still recording okay
okay I'm not the [ __ ] bad luck charm
so anyway the process for coloring there
was actually a question and I saw on
Twitter the other day when we asked it
was someone asked if there was like a
process for inking and coloring there's
actually not any inking in this book at
all at all and that's that's insane like
that's unheard of but the process just
works well enough that we can get away
with it yeah
because it like having the lines be like
kind of fuzzy and not super like you
know sharply inked every on every page
it adds to kind of like the the
compression that that show has being
permanently stuck in standard definition
yeah all the lines are a little bit
sketchy and like kind of fuzzy on
everything it always nothing is really
crisp ever and it's a very specific
aesthetic that we decided like kind of
late into it that we're like late into
the planning stage we're like we want
this to look like it's on an old VHS
tape
and you can see my my [ __ ] beautiful
play and eject buttons on the beginning
yeah that was anyway the process for
coloring however since that's that was
my job
we I just like looked at a lot of shots
from the show we collected [ __ ] it
seems about screen caps from the show
and we [ __ ] really I have one that only
has like 410 yeah I need every character
from every angle cuz I'm the one that
has to create it I think I only have two
model sheets in here and it's just one
for Peter and one for spider-man and the
colors on them aren't even right there
just cloaks guys have been looking at
the the colors and characters enough to
like just tell if it's wrong just by
looking at it yeah now like well usually
cuz Dane actually did help me color a
little bit once we were getting into it
like a time crunch he would start the
flats on the characters for me but there
I would do everything else backgrounds
and shadows and and sash but I like once
we got into that stage and we already
had like pages from the same kind of
like location colored so like we already
knew that we were using night colors on
a certain character backgrounds we would
just start color grabbing from like
previous pages so we knew that those
colors were writings we're grabbing from
you know the page that I used which I
grabbed colors from the show so it all
carries over yeah so yeah it's it was
just like watching the show a lot
looking at how the shadows react in
specific shots with different type of
different types of lighting we have the
color palettes from day and night and
inside of a
right room which is slightly different
sometimes from daytime light and inside
of a dark room which is different from
nightlight sometimes it's really [ __ ]
weird how it slightly differing each
time they they have like like a
different palette for pretty much every
kind of environment you can imagine the
character in but they're so similar that
honestly I think I've probably [ __ ] up
on at least four of these pages but no
one's noticed no one guy I think that's
like impossible to notice unless you're
like actually going through and finding
the like vector code for the the color
it's like oh this one is is 17 9 red
that's not like no one no one cares dude
and well after a while you stopped even
color picking the the shadows you just
started like just doing those on your
own I yeah I did those I did that for a
few pages but I went back to the other
method that I was doing before once I
got procreate I don't think anyone can
help
I think that's yeah it just worked no no
no it just worked it's it's like Skyrim
it just works
all right now it's the other game yes
just [ __ ] you really know better that
reference kicked ass everyone's so proud
of me they're like dude that reference
was high tier like holy [ __ ] thick with
the nineties references the one thing I
didn't think we'd be able to do in color
but Jacob did beautifully was the
difference between characters and
backgrounds the carrier painted flat on
his cell taste you know put over top of
a fully painted background I didn't
think we'd be able to get that look but
Jacob I remember while we were in like
the early stages of it him and I were
like drawing pages uh well he was
drawing pages and I was working on a
script and then he's like there's only
one person I want to color this and it's
Jacob because he colored one of your
early
just like your concept arts for it and
you're both super impressed with how on
model it looked and you can check out my
pilot doing that on my it might be on
screen right at this moment huh yeah you
just watch it here actually don't look
my channel I'm not making revenue I
don't [ __ ] I gotta get that bread
[ __ ] lips telling you masks yeah
sewing only me masks a man it works okay
when are you opening commission slots
again I'm sorry Xavier took them off
never Xavier keep stealing sorry they're
just really high-quality masks okay
but yeah the the painting of the
backgrounds I actually noticed by the
time like we got into those last year
the like the last like eight or so pages
I was like looking for two coloring the
backgrounds more than I was the
characters and it used to be like almost
the opposite for the early pages yeah I
would lay down like the characters
usually first just cuz like I like
coloring the picture of spider-man
coolpix fighting me and doing the same
pose where he kicks the guy in the back
and then like by the time I got to the
pages with Ock and Scorpion and shocker
paint in the backgrounds on those was a
lot more fun cuz like I think it I think
what the difference was was I was using
a free art program that did not have the
capabilities of beforehand and then I
got cry like a world of difference and
then I got I got a program I got
procreate which had brushes that looked
like paint brushes and then I could
paint that's that's how that went but
yeah just it's a different process a lot
of layers being
used for doing like the Oscorp building
and oh yeah the explosions were all week
we have recordings of that that are
probably playing right now maybe yeah
you can watch all those I I think it's
super cool that your guys's art program
just automatically records stuff like
that cuz that that process to me is so
like mind-blowing is taking it from the
pencils all the way to that like painted
background look without actually having
to use a single real life brush it just
looks so perfect and on model and like I
can't think of anything else that's
really done that in the comic before is
like you said like two different
coloring styles for the characters in
the background yeah I really have like
thought I just sat down and tried to
look for comics that do that but even
like like Bruce Timm like you know DC
Animated universe comics even they still
just draw the backgrounds the same that
way they do the the characters with like
flat colors or if they do have a painted
background the characters are a little
bit more painted style so it's I'm not
gonna say it's something that hat
doesn't exist before cuz I'm sure
there's at least one example but it's
something I definitely haven't seen
often before and that's it makes it
really really unique and special I think
the advertisement doesn't lie it's it's
the most it's one of the most on model
[ __ ] fan comics in the universe you
show me a fan comic doesn't look nearly
as on model as this one except those DC
ones those ones are really cool oh yeah
those ones are actually awesome you know
what I should talk to the people who
make those and we could be buddies yeah
maybe I've already messaged them before
perhaps yeah it's it's weird trying to
like interact with and cooperate with
other youtubers because even if they
have a smaller following than I do
because I know them from YouTube I go oh
this guy's a cool youtuber I hope he
likes me when I have like triple theirs
scribers I'm like oh I've watched that
guy's videos he's really cool oh I hope
I'm not annoying I'm looking at like I'm
looking at my at the pages right now
without the lettering on it just my
colors I'm like I really don't I don't
know what like my favorite thing was on
certain pages cuz I know for sure that
like painting the backgrounds for the
all the stuff at Oscorp that stuff was
really fun and I looked forward to it
except for when I was having to colour
rocks and those final few pages there in
a collapsing building so it's just
covered in raw middle of the day Monday
before the book came out I was having a
[ __ ] aneurysm me rocks were falling
the onion [ __ ] but but on earlier pages
with like goblin goblin stuff it was
like yeah I'll put a sky and I guess but
like I wanted to work on the shadows
oncoming space for this one like I don't
know it was it was all just a process
for each page it was a little different
every time just cuz of what was in the
page yeah and well I think that's
something that that's really cool is
just the versatility you have because
like every page was kind of its own
little puzzle for you to solve because
we kept getting to all these new
environments it's like oh here's a
brightly lit room full of characters and
you gotta have different skin tones for
all of them
gotta figure out how to do lighting from
like this particular direction but then
you know this next scene they're in a
collapsing building where it's like dark
and dusty and it's just like a
completely different tone and
environment and and the fact that you
were able to transition so well is just
you got skill you got Moxie kid you got
spunk oxy what was that I think there's
a lot of the heavy lifting to make it
look like the show I made
the colors that I agree to an extent but
also like your pencils are [ __ ]
amazing if there's ever a part that
isn't 100% on mall the way he draws like
maybe this the shot he draws
spider-man's foot a little bit more like
by driving by the end you said that like
poses were starting to get a little
stiff so you eased back into your style
before yeah that you could dozen pages
or so everything was really heavily
referenced and it started looking stiff
and I didn't like it so then I changed
the size of page I was using and kind of
leaned it back on my own sensibilities
in art style well it's something I've
learned is that sometimes you can trick
it if you can't get it like a hundred
percent on model as long as the head in
the face and maybe a couple things like
like the chest like the way you draw
like spider-man's pecs or something like
vitamins so large they're the most
important part of his character design
if you make sure his proportions are
about right and his head is is on models
you can get it if his limbs are a little
bit more sharp and angular his feet are
a little bit more blocky or if his fist
is a little bit more square like that
stuff so you stop noticing because well
his his costume is all the right colors
his chest is the right size his limbs
are the right about the right baby his
head is the same the rest doesn't matter
you used to stop noticing that so you
can you can get away with it in a lot of
spots it just it really worked out is
really a collaborative process between
all of us for how the the book came
together cuz Xavier when writing it had
like a lot of different visions for
certain scenes but like oh yeah action I
would say everything up until like the
final few pages is pretty much exactly
how I imagined it like as I was writing
it I had all the colors and lighting and
tones and characters in my head you guys
made a little bit of an executive choice
with the like the final fight scene with
Doc Ock
shocker and scorpion that I actually
think is better than what I had planned
which was to make it look more like the
Oscorp scenes when it's been like blown
out and like collapsed and broken cuz in
my head it looked more like the the lab
from like like the underwater lab from
the first Green Goblin episode or the
one where Harry finds all the equipment
when he's goblin like really high key
lighting lots of blue tones like really
bright overhead lights that just kind of
bath everything in like vivid colors and
you're like you guys particularly Jacob
decided to go for a look like the more
you know blown-up lab from like some of
the other episodes and it makes a lot
more sets contextually because a bomb
did just go off in that room so why
would all like be on wine shock all
pristine the whole area he's just
[ __ ] carving holes in the walls with
the gauntlets so like the decision to
make it all dusty and dark and and like
blown out look like a like a like a
warzone looked it just looked so much
better and fit so much better that I
didn't even complain as soon as I saw it
was like you know what that's that's way
about it perfect go for it run with that
and that's that's one of the nice things
about collaborating with people who like
really know what they're doing is they
can make big decisions to change [ __ ]
around like that and I trust them enough
to just go for it because I mean these
guys are the [ __ ] pros they kick ass
they they can they can go off-script and
it's fine or even when Dane decides to
draw like scene just a little bit
differently from what I had in the
script usually because his idea is
better because like there's a there's a
really subtle example that I like is
when he beats he beats scorpion and
shocker in the same page the way I had
it described in the in the pages was
like a little different from what got
drawn but what ended up I think I had a
different idea is that he Yanks Shockers
gauntlet at
scorpion but you changed it so he yanked
scorpion in the path of shockers
gauntlet and it just fits so much better
for the action of the panel and just
like it just makes more sense regarding
what happens next with throwing them
into each other and it's just you know
it's those little things that you don't
even mind because it just works clarity
and storytelling you know it's easier to
show it kind of this way being scorpion
instead of trying to communicate okay
it's a it's know that whole action with
all three characters being visible on
one panel yeah yeah like the thing that
I wrote might work better is like like a
screenplay like if we were actually
writing an episode of the show yeah you
could probably figure out a way to show
that but when you're doing sequential
art where you have to convey a lot of
information and as few images as
possible
little little creative concessions like
that have to be made and like I said I
just I trust him to do that because I
mean he's also worked with enough of my
scripts in the past like we've I don't
know I would say he's drawn like like 90
pages of things based on scripts that
I've written over the over the past like
two or three years so and it it just
variants of lost but with different
characters yeah yeah it's like here's
lost with Peter Parker and MJ but like
green Goblin's sitting outside of the
window laughing and that one was really
funny there's there's loss but with
Isaac Clark and Nicole from dead space
and no but but uh I think Dana and I
have a really good shorthand because we
we've worked together so many times
right where are you where you gonna say
if I had to draw I love how he agreed to
it cuz he didn't know what it was the
first time
I use this like I don't get this meme
what is this just like it just just dry
it's funny just do this right and then I
put it in the video and then we started
getting into this phase cuz like los had
like a little bit of like a return it's
one of those memes that's pretty dead
but it came back for a little bit
briefly in like late 2018 so we kept
just blowing them up with variants of
loss and to the point that he got mad at
it and then we started editing stuff
like like a newspaper of Abe Simpson
screaming at the sky with the caption
old man yells at los darn kids and your
memes okay I do want to talk about
because we recorded it and then it got a
lost cause OBS like freaked out for a
second it got one no let me finish I do
want I want to talk about the day before
the comic went up where you and I were
panicking and having to like change
things over and over to get the book
like perfect is uh is I like I said I
think I exported the full comic about
eleven times in that like two hour
stretch that night because every time I
fix something you just went to a
different page and found something else
that was off to and it was getting it
was getting frustrating cuz you're like
hey uh shouldn't this word bubble have a
comma and I'm like stay in your lane
with fixing coloring Shh it does have a
comma now bastard it's okay the time
dilation accelerator is probably the
most important thing in this whole
[ __ ] book and it's not even colored
on this page I was I was neither of us
noticed it so many times that I thought
you know what it's fine I bet no one
else know where to sit either it was
fine
I didn't notice it because I was [ __ ]
tired and had just woken up and got
right back to color and it said okay
it's done and I was tired cuz I'd been
awake that whole day for like fourteen
hours by that point so we're both just
like half asleep just say oh my god okay
you got a color in this rock on this
page that's on the wrong layer the
[ __ ] the tentacle is above the rock
and this one Dane was like I'm gonna
sleep happy knowing that I finished my
part so he probably came back the next
morning and the group chat we have for
working on the book 70 new messages and
just scrolled through them and it's all
just all caps screaming and cussing
we know oh man and and I kept even the
next day after the book was out he found
stuff that need to be fixed because
while I was just scanning my eyes up and
down every page trying to make sure it
was perfect I must have bumped one of
the word bubbles because it was on the
copy I have exported before the one it
was fine so it had to have been that
night is I bumped one of the word
bubbles on my program like just actually
real fast and just just made it like 3%
smaller so it's like [ __ ] up and cut a
word in half and put it on the next line
and it looks stupid and I had to fix it
and it's fixed on a - cobbler like that
oh we can change it on the website maybe
yeah I think I can okay shame and on the
Instagram story posting the comic again
from page nine
Oh one day whatever anyway what some of
my favorite stuff from working on the
comic is either writing the scripts or
lettering the pages where Jacob is like
scrum screen sharing with him and he's
watching the process and this large site
things was a little different because I
would be at school coloring for a bit
realizing savior's sleeping schedule was
just horrible that summer it was broken
like I'm on a pretty regular sleep
schedule right now
but that summer I was like going to bed
at like 7 a.m. and then waking up at
like 6 p.m. but the thing the thing goes
for like with that though is that when
he would go to sleep and I'd be like
halfway through my [ __ ] school day
watch him write the script so there's a
lot of in jokes where I was like writing
dialogue and I'm like I don't know what
to have him say here so I just write
something shocking and a horrible to
make it laughs what spider-man gonna
call Doc Ock in this panel
oh yeah and because I he ends up saying
hey tentacle brain on that page right
but I must have wrote 15 horrible things
before I got to that do you remember any
of them or just the one remember the one
and do you want to say it the one that
stuck out the most was spider-man comes
out from the rubble of the lab that was
just thrown into he comes back out
holding the time dilation accelerator
and he says to his foe hey baby penis I
could just picture his laughter at
school and getting him in trouble I was
like what's the funniest thing I could
write right now that would that would
get Jacob like yelled at by his teacher
and yeah there's a lot of that there
every time I had to write equip for
Spidey there would be like six or seven
different versions of
it where I'm just like what's funny and
also sounds natural for him to say and
then at some points it was just like
like I was just like completely phoning
it in and Jacob was I haven't like
helped suggest things to help me get it
right so I guess we'll give him a little
bit of a writing credit on that you
would like watch me letter while I
screen share so I would take a new page
where the art is done and lay it down on
the canvas and then just go and then
click over and you see the script on my
screen and on this really small panel
the script has a paragraph of dialogue
to fit in it and you're just like what
are we gonna do and I just go I don't
know I don't know let me let me think
all right I remember even Thema sending
pages and some of them actually were
fine like he was sending pages and after
you saw the trials and tribulations of
the lettering process you got like oh
okay
it's kid holy [ __ ] like you'd message me
like we're Dane couldn't see it you're
like can you can we work with that once
to do see need to redraw it and I'm like
no it's fine I'll figure it out there's
spots where it was so bad that you had
to actually like crop and shrink art so
that there was more room for the
dialogue and then redraw [ __ ] like
Jonah's hand on one page or like the the
page where the clone and water clone MJ
is melting motifs shrink that I couldn't
have like the straight-line feature oh
yeah so you could you couldn't draw a
new background for it so you just put
this black like shadowy aura around it
to go this panel is sad and it actually
works really well then during the Q&A
section of this of this podcast I'm
eating fries I wonder if you hear
munching it standing during the podcast
you read the questions yeah we got
questions from you guys we asked on on
our on our Twitter that you should
follow if your because
you know I know that that advertisement
it made some numbers but it didn't make
like usual spider-man usually you guys
go [ __ ] crazy when spider-man's and
they on that I don't know so we got some
questions for you guys about it's more
for you you thing for us and the first
one talked about a little bit but what's
your opinion on the show love it I
appreciate it now is more as an adult
than I did as a kid
and I think that says a lot about the
fact that it's an animated show is
because normally it's the other way
around right yep I really liked that
show growing up although I feel like I
probably saw about as much of it that
Xavier did which was like you know some
of the DVDs and then like a handful of
reruns on TV but I think the difference
was was younger than Xavier when I saw
all that stuff nice talk to spider-man I
just thought he was good I like guys
awesome I want to be friends with that
guy didn't know what the [ __ ] a secret
was back then I knew what a secret Wars
was I actually I remember I only saw the
secret wars episode like way after the
fact and I was like oh my god they're
adapting that and by that point I was
like like twelve and it was like a rerun
I was like I thought they already did
the venom stuff why are they doing
Secret Wars to not how that works in
that series because Venom's popular you
got doom first but yeah I love that show
a lot I actually met Christopher Daniel
bookends twice and got things signed by
him got to talk to him a lot the first
time I met him but I talked a little bit
less the second time just because I had
already talked to him and there was a
line accumulating since the voice
actress were made the place Ariel was
next to him and so they were gathering
quite a big crowd at the convention
um so I yeah although he liked my my
[ __ ] Steve Ditko spider-man costume
like he can't he did he can fought out
that classic spider-man stuff cuz he's a
fan I like how he got to start voicing
that character when he was like like
what like 20 like yeah he's like 20
something like he was really young and
like they were just like hey you wanna
be spider-man and normally they got like
a guy was like 35 and just sound young
but for that they were like no let's get
an actual kid for it
yeah so I really liked the show Dane's
liked it grow up with it when it was on
ok what's your opinion of the show kinda
just it was it was just enough to make
the comic not anymore beyond that like
if it's all and I won't even really
watch it on the rerun so it was probably
my first introduction to spider-man Wow
I would assume because yeah because I
grew up in its heyday yeah you know what
I mean Rogers introduction to spider-man
and this is kind of funny was the ps1
game which is like a weird offshoot of
the cartoon like cuz it has like all the
same characters but it just it shares
only one voice actor no it has Jennifer
Hale as well oh yeah yeah that's right
so it has it has black cat as is the
same voice actress and then Doc Ock and
then everyone else to recast which is
why as a kid I never associated the show
in the game but it was meant to be a
game for the show because they even in
one of the company's footage from the
90s cartoon that advertised yeah which
is weird because it's like
it came out after it like it came out
what like two years after that show had
been canceled and Reno had pretty been
spider-man in another cartoon
yeah they got it's so weird but another
another hint added is that what are all
the characters who cameo is like except
for Human Torch who's a little bit of a
weird outlyer
it's well no she's not sure and well I
mean he's he's a Spidey's friend in the
comics but in that show they never
really hung out but they had Captain
America Punisher and daredevil were all
like the I would say the biggest
crossover isn't that show
maybe blade also counts but he wasn't in
that and all of them made it in and then
for the sequel was the [ __ ] the
nineties x-men that looks like their
designs were straight out of the cartoon
and it was even beast who was like the
one who hung out with him the most
during that crossover episode they got
history yeah he said the word diurnal
and I don't know it means but it's
always stuck with me that that's a
really my diurnal Patrol and I'm like
what the [ __ ] does in what is that a
word is that real so our next question
actually leads in pretty well to Matt
last one what's your favorite episode of
the show Turning Point answer okay
alright okay I'll change it then then
the just of the first venom episode is
just such a solid episode cuz that whole
that whole episode is a fight scene
basically there's like three seconds of
like a breather in there where it goes
to Edie's apartment and then the whole
rest of is just battle it's awesome I
mean like I grew up with the venom saga
DVD and I've probably bought like two or
three of those DVDs because I actually
wore those out which is significantly
harder to do on a DVD than it is with a
VHS yeah
so those venom episode
they're super good like alien costume
saga and like those carnage ones those
are the ones that I know the best the
last episode is also really good with
like spider-carnage and all that those
are definitely some of my favorites I
don't know if I can narrow it down all
right next question will we see new
villains that didn't appear in the show
that's that's just the really that's the
most non-committal way of saying yes
dude check it out how long I don't think
it'll be in the way they think that will
do it cuz there's like a really obvious
way to handle that and we're not going
for that well here's one that we were
talking a bit about earlier but this one
kind of a little bit more specific how
long did it take to nail the art style
for the series was it a lot of trial and
error a little bit think again like we
said it's really similar to your your
regular art style it wasn't that big
event trying to not rely so much on
reference but be able to adapt it into
my own style a little bit more natural
it looked like a Dane drawing yeah and
on my end of it it was like for the for
the backgrounds I think is what took me
the longest cuz you can like compare
like page one and look at like the last
panel of spider-man swinging around the
background in that and then compare it
to like when he's flying around with
Goblin later on and it's like [ __ ]
night and day that first panelist by ear
and swinging around much cuz yeah I
don't know it just doesn't there was a
lot of pencil lines still in there that
we're like they keep it together like
well enough but and I and I kept the
pencil lines in there from the the
backgrounds on the later stuff although
removing them occasionally when I wanted
to get in there for highlights and such
but yeah like I wanted to not have to
rely on the pencils I wanted to get
those painted textures like you
noticeable because I mean in those first
few pages they're very smooth it's not I
wouldn't really say painting in the
beginning it's kind of just like things
have gradients to them but I but I
started getting better at that by the
end of page two and definitely by like
page seven I was I was kicking it yeah
pick it up and start drawing you know 94
Peter I still did a handful of my own
model she does just to try and so I'm
not constantly rough though so you know
if I had to drop Peter on a page and
three images of them I could just run
stuff like that didn't you draw the time
dilation accelerator ruffling in like on
page two or something I actually I
changed I changed it on one page like
the scene in the lab there was a detail
on the backk the like [ __ ] battery
pack I guess is what it is and like you
drew it a certain way and I was the
reference image I had like in procreate
looking at it it was different and I
said oh this is wrong I'll just fix it
really quick and then like I was
watching an episode on my TV for
hobgoblins using it and I saw the back
of it out of the corner of my eye and it
was the way that you drew it I said what
the [ __ ]
model my own bottle sheets at least I
could be consistent yeah in the way I do
it but it's still a little different on
page two that it shows up at the end of
the yeah this person is just asking for
spoilers we can probably ask for we
could probably answer one of them he
asks what will the main plot be who are
the main characters why would you ask
that we can't
you wait hey who dies an endgame I
haven't seen it yet I just want to know
where I watch it no read to find out
read to find out character is spider-man
you might have not known spider-man he
shows up he's like hey it's me
spider-man
that's actually pretty this was pretty
clever Jacob I like that it worked well
well Spidey team up with other Marvel
characters well say yes no maybe I don't
know tune in to find out tune in to find
out let's like shotgun him let's go
through these fast cuz the the the main
segment of the podcast ended up being
way longer than I thought it would be do
you plan on introducing elements from
the comics that weren't used or weren't
created while the series was on the air
hi burp during the middle yeah maybe I'm
not sure
like I'm not intentionally going here's
a thing from the comics I wish wasn't
yeah we're not really adapting
storylines from the comics this is a
pretty original story although there
there might be something that was like
in a comic at some point in there but it
wasn't like an intentionally direct
reference it was just like kind of a it
was it was more than likely just a
coincidence or something that I
particularly liked in the comic and then
just like subconsciously put in there's
one that you did specifically do for
issue 2 near the end all right yeah
you're right so there's one there's one
for sure that I know that I was like
yeah that's the thing from the books
that I want in the show or like if they
got more episodes I would like so yes
there's one we'll say that this this one
asks with you guys making a continuation
to the 94 show were you guys ever do
continuations of other stories such as
Raimi spider-man probably not it just
takes so much effort you know I
it's we're also only really good at
drawing the one art style so price tick
with this yeah no yeah trying to learn
like different art styles would just be
yeah I like especially spectacular let
me now just be that that would that
would take a lot more effort than I
think we're willing to put in for a fan
coming you know I'm gonna burn your
house down next question are there any
other planned projects like this that
you want to do after the book is done uh
I would like to finish our original
comic that we worked on for a couple
months that we could maybe get published
and sold in stores that would be nice
but like we'll do that later
my girlfriend's been inking some of that
yeah it looks pretty good what K that
she accidentally flattened the layer on
it so now we can't use it school she was
just already screaming because it's like
I saved this and it was fine and I
opened it today and it's [ __ ]
to make this comic yeah Dayne just found
that he found that model sheets and
we're like we can use this how many
issues do we have planned for right now
five there you go oh that's it just very
simple very simple answer here we go how
long did this take issue one took from
like the end of March till the Tuesday
it came out yet like we were working on
it like that morning and I think like
that's one of the longer issues I don't
know I think the the later ones are
shorter than Xavier thought they were we
we thought there are gonna be like 30
pages each and then I look back and I
was like wait this one's only 20 this
one's 21 they're less than the issue one
we could get these done probably way
faster there's like four or five less
pages yeah but I think originally Oh
before issues yeah we had no way my my
idea for the last one got too big so I
had to cut it in half well there was
also some unfinished business from from
some other stuff that would have just
taken a long time to finish yeah
always had to become a whole issue yeah
like there's just an idea that was like
too big did just like rush through and
like a five page segment it just
wouldn't have felt authentic to what we
were trying to do so it had to give it
more more room to breathe next question
asks what are the what was the hardest
part of making this comic and what's
your main goal for the future of this
top ah the hardest part was that
probably the just the art in general
because like I wrote it over the course
of like a week and we've been just
coloring and drawing for god knows how
long
right pretty much yeah like the cover we
had we had a cover for a little bit that
I started coloring and then was like
I'll work on pages for now and then like
well like a week or two before the issue
came out Dane was like I'm gonna draw a
new cover I don't like the look and we
were like pretty sure on it - we were
like yeah it's good good cover I like it
honestly I think the new one looks
better I can I put the old one up on
screen as like yeah like the most
completed version of it that's available
so be aware that it's unfinished but
yeah this is what we had before up the
pebbles next to it - yeah
anyway somebody somebody asked I'm sure
this will get answered but how'd Captain
America get out of the Phantom thing he
was stuck in well okay my logic behind
that is that like Madame web had her
powers like pull him out of stasis to
bring him to the secret war stuff and
after he let him webbing
it was mad at ya Madame web and beyond
her cuz they were facilitating the whole
thing I kept thinking to myself they
said that they're gonna put everyone
back where they came from
after Secret Wars was over before taking
spider-man on the spider-carnage
adventure beyond her and Madame web
would be a couple of the biggest
[ __ ] in the universe if they put him
back in purgatory stasis cuz like just
he just [ __ ] spent all this past like
week trying to save this planet you're
gonna drop him back into stasis to fight
red skull again just put him on earth
just just dump him in New York so then
he can just go do that now I I thought
that would have been better for the show
if they had done that if they had
acknowledged that they did that but and
that is what questions for how he shows
up in later universe animate it yeah
next one is will Ben Riley show up and
smiles Warren took our Peters DNA why do
people keep asking for spoilers we just
saw Ben Riley I don't think we need is
in the last episode we'll see if the the
Ben Riley Minh has any kind of cameo I
never never say never but uh I don't
know uh some part of me deep down
actually doesn't know cuz I can't
remember exactly what I wrote because it
was all written while I was half asleep
so Janette maybe maybe why do you want
me to answer correctly then sure no
what's your most disliked episode of the
90s cartoon uh I didn't like me of any
of the Morbius ones any of the [ __ ]
Forgotten was the six forgotten warriors
yeah
that arc dragged so long and was so full
of stuff I did not care about we have to
go find why is it whenever we introduce
Peter Parker's parents it's just not fun
yeah every time you bring them in it's
always got to be the dumbest thing you
can think of used to work for Red Skull
but it was a clone of Red Skull and now
they're robots and the other red skulls
killed but the real one comes back and
is trying to assassinate them and then
they don't know a spider-man and then
maximum carnage happens and then it's
just like whenever you read maximum
carnage there's just like a couple of
segments that are really weird out of
context now where Peter just goes and
talks to his dad and if you didn't know
the prior about the [ __ ] stuff it's just
it's not fun it's stupid I hated every
second episode because there was a lot
of em Jacob theater and helping out with
him being spider-man I like that stuff
gladiator [ __ ] is lame I'm gonna help
spider-man they're like kill her
I you know what that was one of those
episodes where I was just like oh I
don't care about this I'm like it's not
relevant for the comic and it's like not
something I really particularly am
interested in so I just completely
checked out and just like started doing
something else like I think I was
editing a video while that episode was
playing so I none of that absorbed I
don't know what any of that was really
okay we love the show but there are some
episodes that are really rough and it's
like
that one yeah any good show uh you know
what
I'm certain if I went back and rewatched
it right now there's probably an episode
or two from spectacular spider-man where
I'm like I could skip this one I don't
like this one [ __ ] hate the Colonel
Jupiter episode of that show
I don't mind it cuz venom has some cool
parts in it I only watch the venom part
oh well yeah there you go
but even that I thought the fight with
Colonel liked the fight at the end with
Colonel Jupiter was fine yeah anyway
we're getting off topic back to
questions anyway do you plan on bringing
venom back in this story to give better
closure to his character and maybe it's
a lethal protector why continue the
animated series other than any any other
spider-man because I think it's the one
that got Jack the absolute hardest
except for well I don't know I mean
there's a lot of different spider-man in
show em spider-man had it pretty hard
MTV's but I think the one with like
spider-man the animated series was that
like it was the one that ran the longest
so the fact that it like had all this
stuff built up to a happy ending that
never came like hurt the most cuz all
the other ones are like here's like you
know a bunch of here's like 10 or 13
episodes of just a pretty decent show
and then the cliffhanger sucks but it
wasn't something they were building up
to for like three seasons you know MJ
goes missing in in the in like halfway
through and 3 which is almost halfway
through the show like a little over half
and we spend all this time building up
to her coming back and then never see it
so it's the one where you feel like you
just it earned a proper ending the most
so it's the one that's like the that
hurts the most because they didn't get
it yeah so yeah the whole the whole
thing is just we love this part
killer version of MJ so much and she's
just just so cool my god she's cute
she's a nice lady
goddess MJ yeah you got it somebody asks
is there a meaning to light what to buy
our comics and read our comics and and
support our comics there you go what did
he do any of those what is what huh
what's the end game for this comic to
make a cool comic that people enjoy
that's that's the end game that's our
goal
and also to have Spider Man finally get
laid after all these years is a good
question i retweeted this did you
utilize high-tech software such as
spider-man cartoon maker to build the
storyboards yes absolutely I don't even
know what that is but I'm gonna say yes
nein spiderman cartoon maker a Miata
correctly yes hell yeah when drawing
when drag fight scenes or writing the
dialogue did you hear like the music and
like you know the sound mixing and such
from the show yeah I actually would
sometimes throw on the old soundtrack
from the show to help me get in the mood
for writing parts of it
so definitely I really helped me make
sure like to keep what kind of tone and
pace I was goading and going for cuz the
music fits perfect for that show you
know I I think I I watched this show so
much like while I was coloring during
that last week just to crunch it all in
that I realized when I was just walking
around
I heard the soundtrack from the show
holy
[ __ ] immersed you may have some kind
of minor form of psychosis it's my brain
now somebody yeah somebody asked if we
would see new villain that didn't appear
in the show this guy's asking but we
just see new characters - oh no I think
pretty much every character in the story
that plays a part is someone that like
was a player in the show at some point
that we saw because the whole idea is to
make it a love letter to the show so I
felt like adding a lot of new original
characters for it wouldn't really just
make it a little antic yeah that's - fan
fiction II that's that's something I
hate in fan fictions actually is just
adding characters out of nowhere like I
wanted to play with the toy box that I
was presented of just here's this set of
characters in this set of characters
from these things so you know stuff that
was already established instead of
trying to create something entirely new
because the idea of like ending a show
like I've always stood by the this this
writing advice is when you're trying to
end a story don't introduce a new idea
or new character right at the end of it
because then it just feels cheap and
kind of messes up like the the whole
point of concluding everything cuz it
just it establishes something new
instead of closing off something that
was already there all right it's pretty
sawed up so good work everyone I loved
it thanks everyone for for showing up
and uh thank you for listening to this
podcast and check out issue 2 whenever
it's out I'm not sure if we'll do
another ad for it on the channel I
probably probably will just to make sure
people know it's a thing still go but uh
be on the lookout and make sure to go
follow us at the appropriate social
media so you'll always keep getting
updates and you know what the nice thing
now is that now that this is no longer a
secret project we can post updates of
things
like little hints and teasers yeah cuz
we were just non-spoiler wheel
non-spoilery yes we were doing teasers
uh to the lead-up of announcing it but
it was always very like it's kind of
vague you know this could be a Spider
Man thing for sure but what spider-man
thing we didn't want to say the biggest
giveaway was the Daily Bugle one that
had stuff about Red Skull
Heckscher oh but I feel like only if you
would know no one really like read that
though yeah I feel like a lot of people
knew from that one though because a lot
of people were like oh animated series
on Instagram at least hell yeah alright
anyway thanks for checking it out and
we're glad you guys liked it and we love
you so much and read it again if you
haven't already and but